(suspenseful music)
(man speaking in slow motion)
- No!
- Slap ass!
(upbeat beatboxing theme music)
- What a mind-blowing finish
to an incredible game tonight
with Charlie Sanders winning the game
in literally the last second.
Unbelievable, truly spectacular.
Charlie Sanders, how does it feel?
- Hey y'all, I wanna say
something to everybody watching.
Yo, you can do anything.
Anything's possible. The world is yours.
- Charlie, did you think that that game
was gonna end that way tonight?
- Yo, there are no limits, all right.
You can swim across the Atlantic.
You can jump real high and touch the moon.
- Fantastic. Charlie Sanders,
fresh off of his victory
and just feel like he's
ready to touch the moon.
- I can fly.
Anybody can fly.
If you believe in yourself
the way I believed in myself tonight,
you will fly.
- And what's next for Charlie
Sanders and the Orange-
- Kids, you can actually fly.
- No. No, not literally.
- Yes, literally. Kids, young kids.
Once you go up on your roofs right now.
- Wait, what?
- Fly into the night sky.
- Okay?
- People will see you flying
and then you can do anything.
You can do anything.
- Okay, well, we just
wanna remind the kids that
of course you cannot actually fly, kids.
- Come on, yo, screw that negativity, man.
Hey, boys and girls, ages 8 through 12.
Yo, don't let nobody ever tell you
what you can and cannot do.
All them pre-teen children
out there, listen to my voice.
You are immortal.
- Okay, well, obviously we understand that
Charlie is super excited right now
and that no one is actually
immortal, nobody at all.
- Kids! You can turn yourself into a car
and have a friend drive
you onto the freeway.
- Okay, nope. Well, that's
just a metaphor, kids.
- It's not.
- Just a metaphor.
- You still have the power
of childish innocence.
Get a friend on your back
and make a beeline for
the next ramp to the freeway, y'all.
- Okay, don't do it-
- To the freeway.
- He's speaking figuratively, folks.
- No, once you get there,
ain't nothing figurative about this,
you will turn into a robot.
First and foremost I just wanna say
to the 12 families who lost children,
I'm sorry, my statements
were irresponsible.
I have subsequently looked up
the terms literally and metaphorically
and found that whereas
I was not incorrect,
they did not mean what I
thought they had meant.
- Hey, J'Dinkalage.
- Yeah, L'Carpetron?
- Check out Leozz.
I wonder what he's dreaming about.
- He is probably dreaming about
what we is going to do to
the team from the West.
- I wonder...
(twinkling harp music)
(funky '90s hip-hop music)
♪ T'Variusness, T. King for short ♪
♪ I'm a bad mamma-jamma
and a awful sport ♪
♪ Smoochie-Wallace, you
can call me Tyroil ♪
♪ Wrapping' up rushes
like aluminum foils ♪
♪ McCringleberry, I'm very scary ♪
♪ If I've got the ball, you best be wary ♪
♪ L'Carpetron Dookmarriot ♪
♪ I love the ball so
much I wanna marry it ♪
♪ 'Cause the Eastern schools' ♪
♪ Gonna beat the fools from the West ♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Where football's concerned ♪
♪ We gonna show you that we are the best ♪
♪ We are the best ♪
♪ I'm Ibrahim Moizoos ♪
♪ And my rhymes are clean
like my name was Dr. Seuss ♪
♪ Probincrux the Third,
they call me the Probe ♪
♪ I can intercept balls with my earlobes ♪
♪ Shower-Handel, that's my name ♪
♪ Power candle sounds the same ♪
♪ With Jackmerius, D'squarius,
and Javarison-Lamar ♪
♪ Flaxon-Waxon plays sax and ♪
♪ D'Marcus plays guitar ♪
(sax blaring)
♪ 'Cause the Eastern schools' ♪
♪ Gonna beat them fools from the West ♪
♪ Okay? Don't you know ♪
♪ Where football's concerned ♪
♪ We gonna show you that we are the best ♪
♪ Indeedy we are the best ♪
(L'Carpetron gasping)
- It must have been all a dream.
Or was it?
(funky '90s hip-hop music re-starting)
- Hey, hey, come on , good game. Slap ass.
Slap ass. Slap ass. Slap ass.
Hey Garcia.
- Get up out of here!
(screaming in foreign language)
- Ah, slap ass, slap ass,
slap ass, slap ass, slap ass.
- Yeah guys, way go go.
- Good hit Garcia.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey. Knock it off.
You can't do that.
Guys. Guys, guys, listen.
Rafi just got out of treatment. Remember?
We don't want to trigger
him with any slap ass.
- Hey! What the (beep)?
What going on here?
Why we all acting at the funeral here?
- No nothing. Rafi.
You just caught us in the
lull in the conversation, man.
We're happy.
(team cheers)
- I was gonna say for a second.
Cause I mean, that was a good game, huh?
Good game!
Hey, good game!
Good game, man.
Good game.
Okay.
There's an elephante in the room.
You know, I wanna talk about it.
See, I had a problem.
It was bad.
At my lowest point, I was
sneaking to a horses' stable.
When you find yourself
at 1:00 AM in the morning
with your hand in the air
and a horses' ass is
in front of your face,
that's when you know it's bad.
But I'm okay now.
I'm all better guys.
Honestly, just treat me
like I'm normal, okay?
- Okay Rafi.
- Lets have some fun.
- It's a game.
- It's all right!
(beep)
- It's a good game.
- Garcia, you can pick up your glove.
Come on, pick up the glove.
Hey, what I told you, huh?
It's just normal guys.
Come on.
See I'm fine.
I'm all better now.
You guys can do the normal stuff.
Be yourself.
Bend things over, pick
things up, you know,
do your stretches, touch your toes.
You stupid (beep).
- Excuse, por favor. Hola amigos.
My name is Ruben.
I just came over from
the Braves foreign team.
I'm from the Dominican Republic.
(group cheers hello)
- We're all from Dominican Republic.
- I'm really excited to be
working and playing with you all.
Go Rhinos.
(team cheers)
We're all from Dominican Republic.
Welcome to the squad man!
- [Rubin] Thank you.
- Good to see another...
- [Rubin] Muy Bueno. All right!
- We're gonna hit him in the balls.
- [Rubin] Whoo!
- They really put your locker
right next to my locker huh?
- I guess so.
- You got this man.
- Spending a lot of time
down there, you know.
Hey, I have a lot of stuff.
- Yeah.
- A lot.
- I see that.
- Rafi you can do this.
- Oh, oh my goodness.
- You okay there buddy?
Not looking too good.
- I am feeling a bit flushed.
- You know, I got a
good feeling about you.
Maybe we could be good friends.
Maybe even the best of friends.
- Maybe another time.
Another place.
But not here.
Not now.
- Well, either way, we're teammates,
and so anything I can do for you.
Ask away.
- Got it!
- Go Rhino!
- Okay.
Yeah! Uh.
- Oh no.
(intense electronic music)
- No Rafi!
- Slap ass! I want to slap
ass! I want to slap ass.
- You can not play slap ass.
- Yes, slap ass.
- You can't have the slap ass.
- You can give me the slap ass!
I need the slap ass!
- You cannot have the slap ass.
- No slap ass! No slap ass!
No slap ass! No slap ass!
That's what you're going to do.
- I'm so excited! I'm so excited!
- No slap ass!
- I am so, so scared.
- I know.
It was just too hard to resist.
- Okay.
- Are you okay?
- I'm okay.
- Okay.
Okay.
- Hey guys.
You know, maybe after a game victory
we could all go dancing
right? Huh? Ba, ba, ba, ba!
- No!
- Slap ass!
(contemplative music)
(upbeat contemporary music)
♪ Oh I want you ♪
♪ But I don't don't need you ♪